seit jahren gibt es blutige bürgerkriege
in mexiko drogenkartelle kämpfen dort um
die macht jetzt ist im internet ein
video aufgezeigt dass kämpfer zeigt die
aussehen wie militärische
spezialeinheiten präsentieren sich hier
mexikanische paramilitärs mit einem
extrem martialischen video im netz
kampfbereit es soll sich um die gruppe c
rotter energie handeln und den stand der
bewaffnung der kämpfer demonstrieren
einige der kämpfer tragen
kennzeichnungen des drogenkartells aus
callisto die männer rufen immer wieder
auch den namen der menschen ein
drogenboss in mexiko
schlimmer als el chapo der mensch soll
sogar frauen und kinder ermorden lassen
[Applaus]
die mexikanischen sicherheitsbehörden
ermitteln aktuell die hintergründe und
überprüfen die echtheit des videos heißt
es sicherheitsminister alfons strasser
bezeichnete das video allerdings bereits
vor abschluss der überprüfung als fake
ja noch wird also geprüft ob dieses
video tatsächlich authentisch ist
trotzdem hat es natürlich vor allem in
mexiko für viel aufregung gesorgt
darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen mit
maximilian kiewel bild chefreporter in
der politik max dieses video wenn man
sich das erst mal anguckt ist
erschreckend was sind das für männer die
wieder sehen genau also wir sehen die
die gangster die kriminellen von
mentschow dem gefürchteten
gefährlichsten kartell boss in mexiko er
ist im land so was wie der staatsfeind
nummer eins die usa suchen ihn mit zehn
millionen euro lösegeld fahndungs geld
und seinem mandant männer sind für
unglaubliche gewalttaten bekannt
massaker enthauptungen kinder sind
ermordet worden schwangere sind ermordet
worden und zuletzt haben sie auch
probiert den polizeichef von mexiko
stadt zu ermorden wenn du dir das video
anguckt was es für dich dass man sagt
das besondere was war schlecht für dich
heraus hat sich das video an guckt also
in mexiko gibt es ja schon jetzt im
schnitt 100 mordopfer pro tag und jetzt
hat man also noch kartell mit
die rumlaufen wie eine spezialeinheit du
hast gesagt taktische westen uniformen
unter zu kriegswaffen wir sehen
kalaschnikow sturmgewehre mit
granatwerfern maschinengewehre die auf
pickups geschraubt sind
scharfschützengewehr mit denen
gepanzerte fahrzeuge zum beispiel von
der polizei erschossen werden das sind
bilder wie man sie sonst aus
kriegsgebieten kennt und es passt auch
ein bisschen
dieses kartell ist soll vor ein paar
monaten von paar jahren schon einmal ein
hubschrauber des militärs abgeschossen
haben
es gab also da schon immer den verdacht
dass die kriegswaffen besitzen und dazu
passt auch dass die usa gerade dran sind
dieses kartell als ausländische
terrorgruppe einzustufen
das haben wir gerade gehört bevor die
untersuchungen abgeschlossen sind gibt
es schon offiziell die sagen es ist ein
fake glaubst du dass es dient mehr zur
beruhigung der menschen in mexiko oder
gibt es tatsächlich anhaltspunkte die
zeigen das kann nicht echt sein also wir
wissen dass die mexikaner dass selbst in
ihrer hauptnachrichtensendung
ausgestrahlt haben dieses video
es gibt in mexiko du hast das gesagt
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände
es tobt genauso ein propagandakrieg eine
propagandaschlacht regierungsvertreter
auf der anderen seite die kartelle auf
der anderen
ich glaube man muss abwarten was
herauskommt aber von dem was man aus der
vergangenheit weiß wie diese kartelle
angreifen mit was für waffen sie
arbeiten ist das stimmig und könnte
zustimmen auf jeden fall
danke für deine einschätzung